when our world is threatened
one team
is ready to launch Disney to say lunch
uh no I said launch
whoa
it's giving off some kind of energy
I didn't do it
no way
this September I think we've got super
powers
and that's why I wear a hard hat
[Music]
look at your paws
great now the clumsy pup shoots
Fireballs out of his paws
but that was a real hits
now how about the PAW Patrol but more
but just a little bit extra
how about
the mighty pups
those would be my superpowers
I'm gonna take them one by one
oh my goodness I could talk
give me that
it's so fun well well Humdinger he looks
different than I remember
one of us
you go up against all of us
now that we're super I'm never gonna get
to sleep well you're probably more tired
than you
oh you've got to be kidding me
I'll talk to me